So the question is Pontius Pilate,
this question,
the first postmodernist what is truth?
And it was taken up many times,
but by nature and the genealogy of morals were all truth is interpretation.
And of course this is not the case with Nisha and anybody who follows him as you
pointed out,
because that's somebody else's truth,
that there is no truth and therefore what do you do with that?
And you're into the problem of the creek and liar.
But here is the problem for me even with your talk,
which is as usual,
brilliant and I think grounded and and tremendous amount of factual information.
I was asked once after a book of mine came out,
which was contested hottie by many people.
What gave me the right to think I had the truth.
This was an interviewer in Toronto for the Random House thing.
And why did I think what I was saying was true.
Who was I to say that I had the truth and I said I don't have the truth and I
have to come up with some explanation quickly and some kind of phrase.
And it just occurred to me.
I said,
all I have is this credible verisimilitude what is credible?
Various similitude he wanted to know.
I said a,
it depends on gathering as much evidence as you possibly can,
even if you have to counter your own biases,
you just said with as least at least amount of deceit or self self-indulgence as
possible.
And the second factor is common sense,
which seems to be not so common these days.
So if you can put evidence and common sense together and at the same time try
and Marshall and monitor your own proclivities,
I went right,
but that was hard with my book as I was left before I could go right.
And I had to make that decision.
Do I want to go right and lose all my friends or do I want to stay left?
And you know,
I have Catherine and join my friends and saw I had to go right?
Because that's what the evidence told me against my own desires.
So honesty,
if you can manage it,
evidence and common sense,
but here's the problem.
Truths,
it's still there.
How do you get from credible,
various similitude to truth.
Where is the bridge?
How do you get there?
Nobody can say that.
Ultimately,
yes,
the problem,
I think you can,
you can say certain things are true,
certain dates et Cetera,
said certain things of happens with men have suffered as a result of feminism.
All of this is true,
but where truth seems to founders,
when you enter the realm of,
because who has the truth to explain why feminism developed in the way it did or
why climate warming or global warming developed in the way it did.
We can point out the facts,
this is wrong,
this is happening.
But when you get out of the element,
the region of events and into the region of the causes,
that's the bridge,
the gap from credible,
various similitude to truth.
And I frankly don't know how to manage that.
So the conclusion I'm coming to is a little bit different from your conclusion.
It's not the one that I want to come to and I would like to resist it,
but the conclusion I'm coming to is quite simply we're fucked.
Yes.
But that's always been true,
right?
That's the apocalypse is always,
that's why the apocalypse is eternal because the world's always coming to an end
and it's actually true small ways and in great ways.
I mean with regards to your,
your ideas about truth,
I would say that like language,
truth is more like a process.
And I would say it's,
it's,
it's a process that you actually embody rather than conceptualize abstractly to,
one of the ways I've thought about it is that if you're seeking the truth and
what you don't know is more important to you than what you know,
and that's a fundamental orientation,
right?
I mean,
what I'm doing,
what I've been doing since September,
and I've had friends who've been helping me with this,
but I think I've been doing this for a long time as I'm trying to figure out
where I'm wrong.
I'm watching the audience to see if I'm making a mistake.
I'm listening to my friends who are watching my youtube videos telling me what
I'm a little too angry maybe or maybe too pompous or too noisy or you know,
all the different ways that you can fail in front of an audience.
I'm listening to them and listening to the comments and I'm trying to modify
myself accordingly.
You know?
And so you live in error and strive towards the truth and it's in that striving
that the truth is most accurately embodied.
But then I would also say one other thing,
and this is what I like about the existentialists is that,
you know,
there's,
there's a kind of emphasis on pragmatic truth among the existentialists because
they claim that your truth is something that you should act out,
not merely hold.
Because to act out is to believe that it's a definition,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's not,
it's not precisely a proposition,
it's a definition.
And so I found some things that I was confident in,
enough into risk acting out.
And so that's what I'm doing to the best of my ability.
And then I'm watching what happens and,
and I'm watching what happens if other people act out the propositions and w as
far as I can tell,
so far so good.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I wouldn't say that my position right now is to be,
what would you envied?
It's very stressful.
I mean since September,
I basically be in a position of
any mistake is fatal for for all intents and purposes,
you know,
and that's very stressful to be that hypervigilant.
And uh,
but by the same token,
the public response to what I've been doing has been overwhelmingly positive.
You know,
I've only got three pieces of hate mail,
which,
which just staggers me,
you know?
And,
and the comments on Youtube for example,
are,
are like 50 to one positive and who,
I mean who,
yeah,
maybe it's a biased sample,
I can't tell but,
but um,
and the other thing know I've been trying to rip holes in the ideas that I
presented to you today for really like with all my intellectual capability for
as long.
Every time I lecture I'm trying to do the same thing.
It's like,
is there something in this that I haven't got right?
Cause I'm trying to,
I was trying to look for some,
a rock at the bottom of things,
you know,
and partly why I decided that I wasn't going to use those damn words is because
I think the rock at the bottom of things is honest speech.
I really believe that it,
it seems to me to be right and that's good enough.
So I'll act that out and see what happens as best I can.
I mean,
I'm not claiming to be,
I'm not claiming to be any more honest than anyone else.
You know,
seriously.
I'm not,
I did that.
That's a big claim to make you better watch your bloody step if you're going to
say that.
But that doesn't mean I don't believe that arms speech is the pathway to
redemption,
because I do believe that.
So I know that's strange language,
but you know,
that's still,
it's the most accurate language for that kind of conceptualization.